blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman all right we're going to start
today looking at
an interview billed as an exclusive
interview if you can imagine that by
right wing radical tv network
newsmax with former president donald
trump donald trump of course
giving a completely insane interview
lying about just about everything but
this is the man still at the head of the
republican party this is the man who
most republicans still say they would
vote for
this is the man who most republicans
still say did win
in november and they would follow him
out of the republican party
to his own third party or so they say or
so they say
let's just get right into it we're not
going to be able to look at all of it
but let's at least start looking at some
of it
mr president thank you for sitting down
with us this experiment of joe biden is
president it's only been
four months and in the short four months
america's enduring
numerous crises both abroad and at home
it seems our country is deteriorating
very fast even faster than i would have
thought your reaction great question
well it's pretty obvious you look at
what's going to happen is even
scarier the border is a disaster we had
the strongest border we've ever had and
within
a month it became the weakest and now
you have tens of thousands of people
flowing into our countries and men
so already okay already understand the
number of lies there
the border was a situation under trump
it's a situation under biden it's gotten
slightly better under biden that's the
situation there's a seasonality to
crossings which we've already talked
about
but this is already a framing that's
completely
absurd it's it's this is fantasy world
framing uh and this is what the entire
interview was let's continue
criminals frankly released from jails in
numerous countries we have people coming
in from the middle east we have people
coming in from everywhere
you go to the airport so just casually
that's another
unproven unproven statement that there
are people coming in through the border
from the middle east
he keeps repeating it they all keep
repeating it but there's not actually
evidence
that that really took place let's
continue joe
how you doing you come through the
southern border and you just walk in
we're the strongest southern border ever
and it's very sad to see
uh the wall was so important you know we
built almost 500 miles of wall
remember that most of that was just wall
that was redone
that's all that's all it was i think
about 70 miles of new wall were added
just another lie
and within a month it would have been
finished and they ended it
and of course within a month nothing
would have been finished he he promised
that by the end of his first term there
would be a wall across the entire border
one more month would not have done
anything they ended it
took two and a half years to get the
approvals to do it i had to go to court
i had to do everything we got the
approvals
and so you have open spots and it's
ridiculous i hear they're going to close
them up but now
it's a big deal with the contractors
because those deals were those
those transactions were made it was all
complete but you look at
some ramblings uh it's very sad to see
what's happening
inflation is going to be a big problem
it's going to drive
so free association now on to a new
topic a lot of things
up and down whichever is worse because
uh bad things
did you guys catch that inflation is
going to drive
things up and down whichever is worse
could be up could be down either way
it's definitely going to be very bad
things happen with inflation but you see
that happening all over lumber the cost
of lumber the cost of gasoline
you look at gasoline what's happened i
was at 287
was was high remember that gasoline
prices
started climbing dramatically under
trump
uh presidents have very little to do
with gas prices but
if they started climbing under trump the
reason was there was a complete collapse
in demand for gasoline
at the start of the pandemic at the end
of 2020 things started going the
opposite direction
gas prices were going up under trump
they've continued up under biden because
the economy is opening and because there
is now demand that's when i
got involved right and uh it was in the
threes and a little bit in the fours and
then i got came in and i had it under
two dollars i had it
for a dollar eighty-seven actually and
when i left it was
under two dollars substantially and now
it's it's going to be hitting four
dollars
meaning that's bigger than any tax
increase you can think of especially for
middle-income people so a lot of bad by
the way that's also
untrue if you look at just the average
miles driven by middle-income people
gas at 370 versus gas at 190
it is a difference but it's it's not
significant in the way donald trump
wants you to believe
relative to so many other things child
tax credit
covet cash everything is a lie things
are happening i don't think we're
respected
in the world that's again another
factual
demonstrable lie respect and approval of
the united states
has skyrocketed since trump left we have
studies on this
pew global research we have we've looked
at them dramatically
better opinion of the united states
around the world
since donald trump left everything is a
lie my friends
right now there would never moves on
taiwan by china now you have bombers
flying over
taiwan russia would have never encircled
ukraine
like they did kim jong-un was somebody
that i had a great relationship with
we weren't going to have any problem
with him in my opinion and now you look
at what's going on there a lot of bad
things are happening
i want to ask about the wuhan lab
reporting this week from the wall street
journal
about workers there being so sickened as
far back as november of 2019 that they
were
hospitalized yeah the corporate media
now and we're going to talk about this
later today and tomorrow full bias
corporate media is starting to come
around to recognize
that perhaps that is the origin in fact
of the china virus
even dr fauci is changing his tune do
you feel vindicated
and again his corporate media is
starting to come around to recognize
dr fauci is not changing his tune okay
dr fauci has said all along investigate
things but right now we
don't have evidence this was a man-made
bio-weapon i have no doubt about it i
had no doubt about it
i was criticized by the press because
china has a lot of people taken care of
they
took care of hunter they took care of
joe they took care of everybody didn't
they
and people didn't want to say china
usually they blame it on russia it's
always russia russia russia but i said
right at the beginning it came out of
wuhan and that's where all the deaths
were also by the way when we first heard
about this
now of course remember it came out of
wuhan is very different nobody
denies that that was the human centered
infection source
the question is was it an engineered bio
weapon as they claim
was it naturally occurring studied in a
lab and it accidentally leaked
uh i have no problem investigating those
things as i've said
from the beginning but donald trump says
obvi i know exactly what it was how does
he know he doesn't know anything about
this stuff
there were body bags dead people laying
all over wuhan province
and that's where it happened to be
located so to me it was very obvious i
said it very strongly and i was
criticized
really strong people are agreeing with
me so that's okay
when it comes to china the more we learn
about their malfeasance regarding the
virus and what they knew very early on
and lied to them okay so this is just
normal trump um i guess we would call it
like trump uh
he goes into xenophobic stuff i want to
skip ahead
because of our limited time um to
another part of this interview let's
continue
probably you know tens of millions of
lives worldwide
mr president you mentioned gasoline and
uh right the specific
statistics are on election day it was
220 a gallon national average according
to department of energy right now it's
311. that's a massive move
incredibly quickly since election day i
want to ask you about inflation no more
bro
did you see what they did there guys did
you see what they did
since election day really well who was
president
november december and most of january
this is how they do it okay under big
picture
presidents have very little influence
over gas prices
micro why are we now including since
election day because they know that gas
prices started jumping in late summer of
2020
under trump and they continued
increasing
under trump and yes then then they
continued increasing under joe biden
this is how they take a phenomena that's
observable
and they politicize it there's very
little to politicize actually about gas
prices
biden or trump probably because you did
business in the 1970s the last time the
u.s saw
really aggressive inflation a lot of
people if they're young have never
operated in that kind of environment
in america uh what does this portend for
americans this new
biden inflation spike biden inflation
spike
let's listen well it's going to be ugly
when you look at the cost of a house
just the materials for a house it's up
30 or 40 percent in the last few months
especially lumber lumber they say you
can't even get it
perhaps they're closing down all their
forests for environmental reasons i
disagree
i said let's buy our lumber from
ourselves
so we go to canada and canada is a very
good they are very good negotiators in
canada
i did the usmca which was one of the
great achievements because nafta was so
bad it was so
horrible worst trade deal ever met all
right so so again here there's just so
much first of all
the differences between us and mca and
nafta are relatively modest okay
trump touting usmca is some miraculous
replacement to nafta
just we've done we've done deep dives on
that completely false
this issue of connecting biden to the
increase in real estate prices
uh and lumber first of all under normal
scenarios and during 2020 trump bragged
housing prices are up
trump considered it a badge of honor
housing prices are up that's the sign of
a good market trump's a real estate guy
housing prices are up means developers
like trump make more money
now the same phenomena which of course
is a result of
slowed down supplied lines during the
pandemic combined with
people wanting bigger spaces so that
they can work from home in perpetuity
have driven up the cost of housing in
some markets
and it has made lumber uh a scarce
resource
okay and now trump is saying well that's
bad well you
you were saying that this was good and
it was a sign of how great things were
when you were president it's all
whatever they need to make of it at the
time
although the deals they made with china
were pretty bad too i will tell you that
but uh
the worst trade deal ever made and i got
it done
so we have a great trade deal now but
they
close up forests they don't want to take
down any trees so we end up buying them
from other countries
all right so trump doing economics
always risky and it makes no sense
i want to skip ahead to another part of
the interview just to give us a sampling
of everything that's going on here
so uh it's very interesting what's
happening so i greatly
respect what some of the governors are
doing in some of the states i think they
can solve the problem maybe better than
the federal government
okay but regarding the federal response
if the republicans do retake
the congress as you're very much working
toward in 2022
if you decide to run again and you win
in 2024
in a potentially hypothetical second
trump term what can be done to counter
the power of these oligarchs well i
think what can be done
and very strongly and when you say
oligarchs it's an interesting term but
yeah
i just say big tech because what they do
is illegal but they also
silenced what should have been the
biggest blockbuster story of the entire
campaign
uh you know that i certainly experienced
this from the campaign side the fact
that the hunter biden
laptop from all story was completely
censored and suppressed by big tech
this is the big story for them that
wasn't told
um an incredibly flimsy conspiracy
theory
about the son of the democratic
candidate for president
that's the big story that they believe
was not told
okay my view that justifies labeling
these operators as oligarchs is that
fair well
a lot of things are fair look that was
when we first had
uh silencio that's when we first said
silence
zalenzio that's a little zvanish
with hunter biden because it was very
bad for the democrats that was a very
bad
issue and we'd bring it up and i have to
tell you the new york post was
incredible what they've done is
incredible and it is it is incredible
that's true
yeah the abuse they took it was you know
i think it's a great newspaper actually
and a lot of people are relying on it
more and more
too bad yeah but they are so just i mean
a lot of people rely on fox news too
it's scary
an incredible job in that in that regard
but they took tremendous
abuse but that's when you first saw
silence they silenced
a newspaper it's the oldest newspaper in
our country i believe and it's a big one
but they silenced a newspaper in our
country because they were talking about
hunter biden
and the senate we held if i weren't
involved in the senate races nobody ever
says this
i believe it would be 60 to 40 right now
with the democrats leading by so this is
a very interesting
revisionist history understand that
donald trump becomes president of the
united states as the head of the
republican party
in 2018 republicans lose the house of
representatives to democrats
in 2020 republicans lose the senate to
democrats
50 50 with kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote and in 2020
republicans lose the white house they
lost everything under trump
and trump is somehow still making
himself the hero of his own fairy tale
by saying well
listen many of the seats we held in the
senate were thanks to me
this guy was behind kelly lefler and
this guy was behind david perdue
and they both lost in their special
elections uh in jan on january 5th
and even though it's abundantly clear
that they lost
partially because of his mishandling of
the pandemic partially because
he just made this party a laughing stock
for year after year after year
and he has the gall to say thanks to me
it's only 50 50.
it could be it would have been even
worse if it weren't for me 10 instead of
50 50.
and mitch mcconnell lost two seats that
he should have had he kept talking about
we're going to give you 600
they're going to give you 2 000 who can
win a race like that he said you won't
get a penny more
to the public you won't get a penny more
they're voting and they're
saying 2 000 and he's saying 600
he lost those two senate seats so we
have 50 50. i think you would be 60 40
if i weren't endorsing if you look at uh
so there it is thanks to donald trump my
friends
republicans at least can obstruct things
which need
60 votes 21 minutes
on newsmax of pure propaganda
lies delusions and
complete and uttered meaningless
distortions and
republicans love it they love it and
this is what they want more of in 2022
and this is what they want more of in
2024. is it going to happen
i wish i could say definitely not but uh
this is the republican party that we're
talking about
okay um find the entire interview if you
want to go to the newsmax youtube
channel remember that monday memorial
day we're doing our one day membership
special
membership bomb on monday we'll do a
huge discount off of membership
for the federal holiday if you would
like to be notified
make sure you're on my newsletter sign
up at davidpakman.com quick break
back after this
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to dot
com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported podcast
youtube channel and live streaming
platform
make sure to grab one of those beautiful
memberships by
signing up at joinpakman.com
we have some really great discussion
happening on the david pakman show
subreddit i
and some not so good which i will point
to today you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t here's a post
i spotted this morning and this is
really sad
a user illustrious worth writes my
father is a right-wing conservative and
he's
too deep into magaland he's even trying
to drag me into it
what can i do to get him out i should
probably explain further they write
the majority of my family members are
democrats and my father is pretty much
the only republican in the family
he's been making me listen to
conservative radio for the past few
months so he can as he puts it give you
a different perspective
he does listen to me in my opinions from
time to time but he's the dominant one
when it comes to
political issues i'm going to try to
make him watch an episode
of dave's radio show i think that means
me or at least
listen but i understand that he may not
change his view instantly this
is a really tough thing and this is
affecting a lot of families and in terms
of
advice and deprogramming people as i've
said before
the i don't know what the wholesale
strategy is for deprogramming nearly 75
million trumpists i don't know what that
is
they seem really strongly programmed
it's resistant to change
that programming but the best way is if
you have the time
individual relationships over longer
periods of time it's a lot of work
but it's starting to talk to your dad
about how
did he come to the conclusions that he
came to how does he determine that
something is true and something they
should believe
what does it mean to them that they
believe that's how the world is or
what would it mean to them if the
reality was different
than that which they believe this can be
a big revelation to a lot of people
where they say oh
there's a reason why i'm so attached to
this belief
because if i didn't believe it to be
true it would change my perspective of
this that the other thing
this is really really tough but to be
honest if you're willing to put in the
work the best way the the
the the retail strategy of
building a relationship with someone and
talking to them over months and months
and examining where their beliefs come
from and where their news comes from
it's one of the only ways that you can
really change people's minds but it is a
hell of a lot of work i don't envy
uh that viewer whatsoever now here's
another one this
i don't like this at all i've said
before on the show tell me why i'm wrong
about the things i actually say
tell me where i'm wrong about the things
i actually believe but one of the things
i
i am disgusted by the most is people who
get mad at me about things i didn't say
and someone posted
a reddit thread about my view on masks
that
is not based in anything i've actually
said and the user writes
why david pakman doesn't like wearing a
mask every time
mr pac-maniac talks about how he just
follows the cdc guidelines and how he
doesn't wear it outside gives the
impression he's disgusted with wearing
it
no no i've never expressed that and in
fact all along i've expressed
let's do what the cdc is saying i'm not
an anti-master
the viewer goes on to say i get the
impression he doesn't fully understand
that wearing a mask can also protect you
against catching cold cough
etc from someone else as well as the
seasonal influenza in the winter but he
doesn't even hint at that being a useful
habit to adopt for us society
when seasonal influenza comes this is
the opposite of what i've said first of
all
when it comes to outdoor masking people
aren't catching the virus outside
people aren't catching the flu outside
people aren't catching colds outside
people aren't catching cough outside and
i've actually said
it would be a really interesting way to
deal with flu
if during flu season indoors where
people
actually transmit flu grocery stores or
whoever
said please wear a mask or if people
just decided hey you know what
the experience of covet is going to tell
me during flu season i'm going to choose
to wear a mask indoors
this person is criticizing me for a
belief that is the opposite of my belief
they go on to say why is it that these
types of entitled people such as
david in the u.s always feel their
freedom is being violated when they're
asked to do something for someone else
seems they just don't want others
telling them what to do you people in
the u.s are way behind
you you it's almost like you're
attacking me if as if i were rand paul
i have never made the freedom and
liberty argument about masks what i've
said all along is i've seen no evidence
that this is being transmitted outdoors
but i'll wear it when the cdc says wear
it outdoors when the cdc said you don't
have to wear it outdoors i said that
makes sense to me
i will follow the cdc guidelines and no
longer wear the mask outdoors it's not
about freedom
i've always said i'm part of the team i
will do what needs to be done
if this is what we're doing right now to
show that we are participating in the
effort to defeat
the virus then i'm absolutely going to
go ahead and do it guys criticize me for
things i've said
not for things i haven't said okay join
the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
that's r-e-d-d-i-t is joe biden
abandoning the promised public option
cnbc is now reporting that joe biden's
new american families plan does not
include
the promised expansion of medicare
eligibility and it doesn't
include a provision allowing the program
to negotiate prices directly with drug
companies
dozens of democratic lawmakers cnbc
rights have urged biden
to include these provisions in the
second piece of his economic recovery
plan
biden's plan would make permanent
premium cuts for people buying insurance
on the individual market key democrats
are aiming to include a public option
bill or create a separate one now that
joe biden
is not including it in his recovery plan
democratic senators patty murray
and congressman frank pallone are going
to write a bill to create a public
option
president joe biden did run on expanding
the public insurance market
but this is not in any of his plans so
far
republicans have exposed every effort
have
opposed every effort to expand
government-managed health care
democrats would likely have to look at
doing this either via a budget
reconciliation bill to pass it without
republican support because you're not
going to get republican support for a
public option
or convincing joe biden to put it in one
of his plans
including possibly the american family's
plan
there are lots of democrats absolutely
furious with joe biden for not including
this and i understand that and i'm with
them now
you know that on this program we are
pragmatic and i would like to see
the promised public option done now i
would like to see it done last month i
would have liked to see it done
when obamacare was first put together
i could understand if you said to me the
inclusion of the public option
will never pass if you make it part of
this bill and so it makes sense for joe
biden not to include it i'm just not
convinced of that yet i have not seen
evidence that if democrats hold firm
and go to joe biden and say listen joe
republicans don't want the public option
okay um we're going to need to pass it
via budget reconciliation if we're to do
it outside of this
let's just include it let's just include
it now and if we do this all via budget
reconciliation then we get the public
option done
and let's actually put republicans in a
position to vote against all of this
stuff
now the counter would be if you don't
have
all 50 democrats on board in the senate
then it's not going to pass either way
because you're not going to get a single
republican vote
so this is one of those situations where
there's truth to both sides
do i believe that if joe biden doesn't
do the public option now he never does
it
no i think it's possible that joe biden
would try to do it later on but why wait
why wait that there is no better time
than now to do
something and remember the public option
was the starting negotiating point with
obamacare in 2010.
should we we should have had a better
2009 whenever the negotiation started
we should have had a starting point that
was far more progressive with obamacare
the first thing to go was the public
option with obamacare is it possible joe
biden will do this later
sure yeah maybe let's just do it right
now but you've got to have
all 50 democrats on board it is not
completely clear to me that you have
them
so are the criticisms fair that it
should be done now
absolutely is the criticism fair that
this is evidence biden
is permanently abandoning the public
option no we can't say that
yet we're four months into a four-year
term that being said my preference would
be to do this
right now there is no reason to wait
unless
you don't have all 50 democrats on board
you've got to fight for their votes
you have to negotiate with them okay if
we find out
that it is three democratic senators
that don't want the public option and
were it not for them you could do all of
this via budget reconciliation i would
say you've got to bring those three
people
joe biden brags about being able to
negotiate he brags about being able to
get deals done with the other side well
get a deal done with your own side get
those three hypothetical senators who
don't want the public option in the
american families plan
bring them to the white house and
convince them negotiate
with them do the thing that you ran on
being able to do
as a a diplomat and an elected official
and a deal maker in the senate for a
long time
could it be done in three months could
it be done in six months could it be
done in 2022 or
sure but i would like to see it done
right now
and until i see evidence that it
couldn't be done right now
i believe we need to continue pushing
for it to be done now many of you will
write in and say david this is pathetic
you just got to do
medicare for all many democratic
senators don't support medicare for all
and neither does joe biden medicare for
all's not going to happen right now
okay so what's on the table is can we
get
a public option done an idea would be
get some democrats to lobby for medicare
for all in this bill
and negotiate to a public option i would
be open to that
what i don't want is something that has
no chance of passing if that's the case
we don't know that to be the case yet
if there's no chance of passing there's
no point in holding this bill up
indefinitely
but i've not seen the work done yet that
proves to me you can't force a public
option into this bill right now
if you disagree with me let me know and
we'll have more cover
coverage of this on our instagram page
which you can find at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
while you're there follow me on
instagram
david.pakman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
it's great to welcome back to the
program today grace blakely who is a
staff writer at
tribune magazine and also author of the
book
stolen how to save the world from
financialization
uh grace it's great to have you back on
today great to be here thanks for having
me
so okay let's i want to talk about
whether there will really be
any longer term changes to the economy
into the world of work from the pandemic
you know we we just kind of generally
have this understanding that
things that seem like oh we're never
going back
humans forget humans re-adapt and things
sort of return to the mean in in many
cases
are there aspects of work and or the
relationship of people to to
the economy particularly in in western
economies that you think will be
permanently altered as a result of the
pandemic
well i think as with any crisis what
happens next is really going to depend
on
um what we demand and and how we kind of
choose to reorganize society when we
when we emerge from it
um i don't think that we will see a kind
of return to normal whatever normal
um was because i mean even before the
pandemic we had
a lot of quite deep problems with the
global economy
everything from this kind of long-term
stagnation and productivity and
investment
through to a stagnation in wages through
to
the kind of massive debt crisis that uh
that we were going through
you know in the us people were talking
about a corporate debt bubble um even
before the pandemic started which of
course fed into a lot of the the
problems that we saw at the start
um so there were already all these kind
of deep-seated issues that i wrote about
in my my first book that you mentioned
they're stolen
um so obviously going back to that kind
of normal
would not be desirable we also then had
some kind of more um i suppose longer
term structural problems to deal with so
things like you know obviously climate
breakdown
uh global inequality inequality within
nations as well
and some of those things have gotten
worse over the course of the pandemic so
if we
we look at inequality for example um
globally
we've seen this big divergence in
outcomes between
wealthier states that have been able to
tackle the pandemic um
have been able to have kind of big you
know stimulus programs big
programs to support workers and
businesses and
states in the global south which uh have
suffered from
the largest outflow of capital ever
recorded as a result of the pandemic
and are struggling just to be able to
kind of provide the basic services that
their populations
need let alone put in place the measures
that are going to allow them to recover
and actually a lot of them are kind of
on the verge of defaulting on their
debts and then you know they're not able
to access the vaccine either so
that divergence is going to be really
really problematic inequality within
countries
we've seen this big divide between
people who've been able to amass savings
and who will come out of the pandemic go
out and spend all that money potentially
driving a bit of inflation
and everyone else who maybe has actually
seen their debt
increase and is struggling to make ends
meet so that divide is going to increase
as well
and really what happens next is all
going to be shaped
by policy by you know whether or not we
have a kind of just
um recovery or whether we see the same
sorts of policies as what we saw after
the financial crisis
where the costs of that crisis were
largely borne by working people
to pick one micro issue and see whether
you think it's really relevant to the
bigger picture or it's just something
people are liking to write articles
about
uh there's this idea that okay take
manhattan
um there saw this empty office space in
manhattan because
of work from home and small businesses
moving out and big businesses will re
reduce their footprint and just reduce
the amount of square footage
and then you read an analysis which
takes a sort of conservative
view on it which is yeah you know rents
will go down a few percent
in the immediate but it's still
manhattan it's still really expensive
and then
three four years from now if there's not
another pandemic they'll probably sort
of be back to being close to where they
were
and some of the big offices will be
replaced with
co-working spaces and like it won't
really change the big picture in a
serious way
something like that do you think that
that even ranks when we think about like
the systemic changes or is the analysis
that it's a couple percentage points and
it won't really make a difference is the
correct analysis
i mean the big driver of um like
real estate prices at the moment is not
necessarily demand it's more speculation
particularly in big cities um so in
places like manhattan and london
um there has not been the kind of fall
in uh in rents and particularly in
actual house prices that you would
assume would
happen as people leave the capital so in
london for example
the population has fallen according to
some estimates by around 700 000
um since the pandemic started which is
huge and there hasn't really been too
much of an impact on
rents or uh or real estate prices it's
different in different parts of the
market but broadly speaking things
haven't changed dramatically
and of course the main reason for that
is um quantitative easing
it's this policy adopted by central
banks of creating new money to purchase
assets from private investors which is
pumping tons
and tons and tons of cash into the
financial system
uh i think the last time i checked it
was about nine trillion dollars worth of
new money had been created predominantly
by the big four central banks
to try and prop up the financial system
and actually to try and keep asset
prices high
this is what central banks are trying to
do at the moment they're trying to keep
equities higher trying to keep real
estate prices high
basically because you know if those
prices were to fall
that could create um a wider financial
crisis
uh basically because you know some of
that is used as collateral for lending
and if you start to see that
fall you get a kind of debt deflation
cycle of the kind that we saw
during the financial crisis so policy
makers and central bankers are actually
going for high asset prices or at least
stable asset prices
and this model of quantitative easing is
how they're doing it and that's likely
to be with us
for quite some time now um a lot of it
is going to depend on what happens in
the rest of the economy
you know to do with inflation and
whatever but broadly speaking
central bankers know that the big thing
driving asset prices at the moment
is their policies and if those policies
stop
you could see quite a significant fall
in asset prices which would have kind of
negative implications in terms of
financial stability
but which would actually probably
correct the massive wealth inequality
that we've seen really you know just go
through the roof of the course the
pandemic people like jeff bezos becoming
extraordinarily wealthy basically
because money's being plowed into amazon
shares
because of central bank policy the same
thing is happening in uh
with real estate as well um so unless we
see like a big shift in policy
that probably isn't going to change then
again it is hard to see how the pattern
that we've seen over the last kind of 40
years of just constantly increasing
um house prices can continue forever
so you know it's a real question as to
the interaction between policy
and you know whether or not we see
another shock that does actually lead to
some sort of correction but
i wouldn't put any money on house prices
properly falling in the kind of short to
medium term
yeah speaking of that i i'd be
interested to hear from you if you have
advice for
for my audience about how to interpret i
mean just to give an example about
the home prices because it's something
that that's quite interesting right now
during 2020 um when
demand started to grow in the united
states in suburbs and smaller cities for
people saying
hey maybe i'll just get a bigger place a
little bit further out
work from home etc donald trump cheered
this on and said listen we're doing okay
look at home prices they're actually up
like this is a sign that things are good
in an interview with newsmax two days
ago donald trump said
this inflation stuff is out of control
look at what homes are costing at this
point in time
no one can get lumber and of course it's
a very transparent political attack on
on joe biden but is there some
empirical objective analysis we can do
of to what degree is it good that the
home
prices have gone up and to what degree
is it a problem
i mean it depends whether or not you own
a home right uh and this is really the
kind of
big divide that we're seeing in politics
at the moment i think it explains a lot
of the age divide
and also to an extent the kind of
regional divide that we're seeing in
politics
is the older homeowners um
which is a group that was broadly
created
um during the 1980s as you saw the
liberalization of the financial system
right people were better able to get
mortgages
they could you know purchase homes in
the uk you had mass sell-off
of um formerly publicly owned housing um
and it created this class of of
homeowners who were able to take
advantage of that massive increase in
house prices that we've seen over the
last 50 years
become very wealthy and as a result
become very conservative
uh because you know if you're like on
the verge of retirement or you're
already retired you have a lot of wealth
stored up in your home you have a lot of
wealth stored up in your pension
what do you want the main thing that you
want is to see house prices stable
and assisted stock prices going up right
and price prices actually going up as
well
if you're a young person that's the
opposite of what you want right
and certainly with house prices like you
are probably
struggling to get on the on the on the
housing ladder maybe struggling to get a
mortgage maybe you don't have like a
full-time job that
is the kind of job that will allow you
to get a mortgage um maybe you're like
self-employed or precariously employed
so you know you're really struggling
often to get on the housing ladder
especially if you're looking in one of
these big cities
um and that is often you're also paying
extremely high rents in the private
rented sector right
and you know parts of london people are
paying up to like 50 of their salaries
in rent which is just extraordinary
um and so obviously that means you have
an interest in things being different
right
so this divide between people who want
things to broadly stay the same want
house prices to stay the same
and who are as a result becoming quite
conservative
out of this desire to hold on to the
kind of gains that they've made
versus everyone else who's being shut
out of that system
is i think probably the most important
divide in politics at the moment so so
in a sense it's sort of a political
football in the sense that
you can argue that housing prices being
up is good or bad
depending on for which group group you
are talking
and also what sort of underlying
implications you think it points to
about the economy at large
yeah exactly and i mean you know
economists will will say oh well house
prices going up is good because you're
going to have
the wealth effect of people feeling
wealthier because their house is worth
more
so maybe you know taking the equity out
of that house and going out and spending
it in the economy which is good for the
economy
i mean you know fine obviously if you
were to see a massive fall in house
prices without any corrective measures
put in place
that could have negative implications um
for like overall growth but actually
there's a structural problem here which
is the
you know the fact that economic growth
relies on constantly
increasing wealth inequality right and
like constantly returns
you know increasing at the very top of
the the wealth spectrum is not
sustainable
last thing i want to um talk about is
you know in the united states
republicans for decades now have been
saying this government spending
program is going to make inflation off
the charts obama's
stimulus is going to push inflation off
the charts
uh trump's first coveted stimulus second
covets
okay and and they were more or less
wrong all along and inflation has been
quite quite stable we now have a
situation finally where we're starting
to see some higher inflation numbers
some of it is because we're comparing to
the second quarter of 2020 when there
was a total demand
collapse so part of that may be an
artifact of that
it still sort of remains to be seen
how should we interpret that like is the
idea of the inflationary spiral when
governments do stuff something we can
just
put to bed at this point or is there
anything to it
people get very hysterical about
inflation and this was kind of a proper
neoliberal talking point during the
1980s
basically you know at that time
inflation was
people weren't actually worried about
inflation i mean they would frame it as
being worried about inflation because
they could say well it's the price of
the goods and services that you're
buying that's going up yeah
really it was a mechanism to discipline
organized labor
um so you know you saw uh well for
example in the u.s with the volca shock
interest rates go through the roof
um it created a kind of worldwide
economic crisis so a debt crisis in the
global south
but it was also used as a tool to create
mass unemployment
so that the labor unions could be broken
and this kind of neoliberal model could
be set up
and since then we haven't had the same
kinds of um you know back then yeah
there were kind of some issues with
inflation i mean a lot of it was
actually driven by the oil price spike
rather than anything else but you know
inflation hasn't really been too much of
an issue and actually since the
financial crisis it's been too low
i mean you can think about um
inflationary pressure as something that
happens when
um the output gap closes so that's the
gap between the amount of stuff that we
could be producing
if every resource was being put to use
and the amount of stuff we're actually
producing right
so when you get inflation it's because
you're starting to get to the point
where
all the resources that exist in the
economy are being used to their greatest
extent right or maybe more than those
resources are being used so you're
getting some pressure on prices
but when that isn't happening so you
know there's underemployment under
utilization of resources
you don't have inflationary pressure and
that's what we were seeing because there
was this big
shortage in demand that came from low
levels of investment low levels of
government spending
and just general kind of a lack of
optimism about what was going on in the
economy
legitimately so today what we're seeing
is
because it's less about the fact that
demand is going up demand is going up
and it will continue to go up
it's more about the fact that the actual
amount that we could produce
has contracted so much so that kind of
longer-term supply
side of the economy um has really become
much more constrained
a big reason for that is what's going on
in the rest of the world
and this is why it's really really
important for economies in the global
north aside from the kind of obvious
moral reasons
to pay attention to the global economy
because if you start to see you know um
say the indian variance spreading
throughout the global south
production shuts down right you can't
get access to the commodities that you
know
as massive importers countries like the
us and the uk need just to kind of get
by
then you will start seeing a huge amount
of inflation especially since you have
all these savings
um that middle-class people have and
that they want to go out and spend in
the economy
um so that's i think the biggest
potential pressure that we're going to
be seeing inflation-wise from now on
um and ultimately it's going to hurt
working-class people more than it's
going to hurt
middle-class people no question no
question about that
we've been speaking with grace blakely
staff writer at tribune
magazine and also author of stolen how
to save the world
from financialization grace always great
speaking with you
and you too thanks david the david
pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him so a cnn reporter has
confronted the woman behind the
completely bogus audit of the
arizona 2020 absentee ballots it's
everything you would imagine it to be
now as a reminder there is yet another
so-called audit happening
in arizona where um absentee ballots are
being analyzed with special cameras and
flashlights and
i don't know if it's neon or uv light
looking for everything from
uh postmarks or that aren't supposed to
be there bamboo fibers it's still
ongoing and it's completely hair brained
and it's not going to achieve anything
cnn's kyung law a spoke to
the arizona state senate president
republican karen
fan about the audit that's taking place
in maricopa county
it is completely and uh outrageous
completely and totally outrageous and
we're going to jump right into it and
check out the conversation
good morning senator fan you may not
recognize arizona senate president karen
fann
let's get this thing done she's the
elusive leader behind the notorious
so-called audit happening in maricopa
county
arizona i don't know what's legit what
isn't legit
but why wouldn't we want to answer those
questions do we just questioning
democracy
no i'm questioning the integrity of the
election system
which is the backbone of democracy
that's right which means we should have
full 100 confidence in our democracy and
in our election system
now as often happens with these
conspiracy theorists she says
a karen says we just want to be sure
everything was clean and good
why wouldn't you want to know that ms
cnn reporter
and they are messing with the burden of
proof the immediate question to karen
has to be
what reason do you have to doubt that
joe biden really won
because otherwise you're just opening up
the door to this endless never-ending
unquenchable skepticism
that can never be satisfied which is a
hallmark of many conspiracists
let's continue but you're talking about
trying to disprove
conspiracies if i have to yes why
wouldn't we
if somebody says as something is out
there
i would love to be able to say that's
not true guys aren't you raising more
questions by giving
rise to these conspiracy theories no
again
if someone raises something well what
about bigfoot
why isn't she devoting her time to
disproving
bigfoot why isn't she spending time
trying to disprove that the earth is
flat or that it's spherical or whatever
the point is they conveniently reverse
the burden of proof when it suits them
and that's exactly what karen fan is
doing here
check out this next clip and look at how
she again
reverses it okay so let me ask you a
question
are you 100 confident
that every vote that came in in arizona
or any other state or
can you say emphatically 100 percent
that no
uh dead people voted that ballots
weren't filled out by other people
that the chain of custody from the
minute people's uh
voted their ballots that the chain of
custody was accurate and
and on target the entire time can you
tell me that
i can say that what the data shows us no
widespread fraud so here's the problem
when
karen fan says are you 100 sure about x
in life what is anyone ever 100 percent
sure about we talk about confidence
intervals we talk about material
significance
in a country of 331 million people will
some people try to vote twice
sure yeah mostly republicans who want to
test
the system and then they get caught but
some people will do that in a country of
331 million
will a vote by steve jones jr
be wrongly counted as a vote by his
deceased father steve jones
senior sure that can happen it's not
are you 100 sure about every ballot
because then we can never stop auditing
any election
the question is do i have any reason to
think that whatever anecdotal
irregularities might have happened
would have had any effect on the results
of even one state
and the answer is an emphatic no let's
look at a little more
i i didn't say there was fraud but you
just said chain of custody
yeah chain accounts people that's these
things are all fraud
well i've asked you a question
can you honestly tell me and all the
states that no
ballots from people that already
deceased were not filled out and sent in
i can tell you that what the data has
shown overwhelmingly is that elections
this was most the most
secure election in american history okay
i like some of what the reporter kyung
law is doing here
but i would like to see her turn it
around on karen a little more
karen this isn't about me unless you
have reason to tell me there was fraud
and here's how it was done
and it would have possibly changed the
results or possibly even
uh uh changed the outcome in one state
never mind the the national results
then it's not for me to prove it you
have to prove that to me
you want the audit not me so bring some
real probable cause
here's one more clip first of all when
we talk about transparency
from day one the entire process has been
live streaming
so anybody on oan with cameras
controlled by oauth are you saying that
oan is not a credible
uh news news source are you saying that
okay i'll remember that cnn is saying
that oen is not a credible one yes okay
very good okay so there's a lot i could
say there but i'm just gonna opt out and
present that part without comment as
funny as it is it is
funny that karen seems to think that's a
gotcha moment
when the world sees that and says what
is wrong with this woman
imagine if the money that people donated
to this nonsense
instead they donated to
environmental initiatives education
eradicating child poverty like
this amount of mental energy
i guess what we would call activism and
financial contributions
would be better uh used
for almost anything than
donating to look at ballots under uv
light
and with spectrometers or whatever in
arizona from a six-month-old election
when even if you somehow managed to
prove that donald trump really won
arizona
it still would not change the overall
results of the presidential election now
more than
six months in the past it is stunning
stuff
and this is real money and brain power i
mean okay brain brain
brain power maybe is the wrong word but
it's real people's time
and money that could be used to dealing
with something that actually is worth
dealing with it's pathetic and they're
just not going to stop
i'm actually not going to be covering
yesterday's mass shooting in san jose
california
because i have quite literally nothing
to say about it that's new and what i
mean by that is
it's another shooting we've had like a
dozen in the last week or so
we have no political will in this
country to do something about gun
violence not all of us but
because republicans have so much power
they don't want to do anything about it
you have a movement which wants more
guns out there every single time there's
a mass shooting
and i can't think of anything to say
since we've covered so many of these
shootings but there is an
ancillary story related to yesterday's
shooting
that i do want to cover retired new york
police department detective pat brosnan
was invited on fox news to comment on
yesterday's mass shooting
and he bizarrely blamed coronavirus
vaccination for the shooting and said
you can bet the shooter himself was
vaccinated now i couldn't believe this
was possibly
an actual analysis being made by a real
guest
on fox news one of the three major cable
news networks in the united states but
it happened
let's jump right in and you will quickly
see that pat brosnan
appears to have something not
functioning quite right in his brain
good morning harris uh actually uh i in
a in a rational world
where there's adherence to the rule of
law and respect for law enforcement
say pre uh the summer of love of 2020
i think there would be more uh nuanced
response in terms of
uh opening a shooting and active
shooting right next door to
where there's a load of armed uh
professional shooters under law
enforcement
but the rules have changed you know
crimes are no longer illegal
uh there's no longer enforcement of lots
of laws and there's an empowerment of
these active shooters
so first of all how could a former
police officer make such a silly
analysis
if people still respected law
enforcement
no mass shooter would even think to
start shooting near a police station
the shooter planned to die what does he
care
if there are police nearby and what does
pat brosnan mean crimes are no longer
illegal by definition crimes are
illegal acts but is he saying we no
longer prosecute crimes
just from hearing this part it was off
to a bad start
but then he gets into vaccination and
you know harris this is a time that i
wish i was wrong with my
prediction which i mentioned to anybody
who listened
that once uh once coverage starts to
lift
these cowardly shooters uh will come out
exactly in tandem with the number of
vaccinations you can be sure they
probably got vaccinated
they were just scared to come out and
they're coming back and you see the
numbers don't lie the shootings are up
dramatically
skyrocketing actually on active
shootings throughout the united states
as we've come through this uh pandemic
it's really terrifying stuff
you know pat as we listen to that very
brief news conference one of the things
that i picked up on
so the host there harris faulkner
has nothing to say about this absurd
hypothesis
he says look mass shootings are
increasing as vaccinations increase
mass shootings are increasing as people
are gathering in groups publicly again
pat brosnan is acting like his
prediction was notable
in some way i've been saying on this
show many others have said
we are seeing mass shootings increase
again as
things are reopening mass shootings are
standard operating procedure in the
united states
sadly tragically disgustingly when
people go back to work
when people go back to commuting when
people go back to socializing as we
exit the pandemic there have been and
will be more mass shootings
it's not vaccination and at the end he's
really off the deep end because he says
i bet you this shooter was vaccinated
first of all at this point
everybody should be vaccinated and what
i mean by that is
we've had more vaccine supply than
demand for more than six weeks now most
of those who aren't currently vaccinated
they're not necessarily anti-vaxxers but
they've not yet been determined enough
to go and get a vaccine because they
could have done it
okay but he seems to be suggesting that
the shooter was waiting to get
vaccinated
before doing the mass shooting the
shooter appears to have planned to die
yesterday
if you plan to either shoot yourself or
get police to shoot you
after shooting up your workplace why are
you waiting for the vaccine
maybe you want for your workers to be
co-workers to be back at work so that
you can have a bunch of them together to
shoot okay yeah that may be something
you're waiting for
but what a completely hair-brained idea
and this is by far the stupidest way
i've seen to criticize vaccines uh from
from the entirety of this pandemic if
there has
ever been a cautionary tale about
understanding the difference between
correlation and causation
it's looking at an example like this
mass shooters
are not notoriously fastidious
about being vaccinated before going out
and doing a mass shooting
it there's just we that that's not the
case and then it's also important to
mention
implicit in his argument is that
coronavirus shutdowns
are good in terms of they limit mass
shootings
my guess is this is not a guy who is too
thrilled
with coronavirus guidelines just from
how he talks dismissively about
vaccination
but what he seems to be saying is when
we were quote
locked down which we never were it
actually did work
to decrease mass shootings which is an
interesting thing to hear from a guy
who is making no sense about any of his
arguments disgusting
sick argument to be making we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p
here is a vaccine-related voicemail this
is a new conspiracy
that vaccinated people are shedding
vaccine
and if you spend time with a vaccinated
person
you might feel sick because they are
vaccinated this is wild
listen to this hi david my name is
ashley
i'm currently 18 weeks pregnant and uh
congrats
vaccinated with the both doses of my
thyroid survivor vaccine
feeling very happy about that um but
what i actually want to talk about today
is
something i've noticed spreading in uh
anti-vaxx groups
i am not an anti-vaxxer but i have seen
this because my cousin's wife
is a hardcore anti-vaxxer it is this
insane notion that vaccinated
individuals they believe
are shedding their vaccinated
immunity i don't know what they think it
is yeah two unvaccinated people standing
nearby
to the point where it is causing
unvaccinated people
uh to have menstrual irregularities
heart problems they're basically blaming
any medical
new thing that happens to them on
vaccinated people
this is exactly what they're doing so
remember at first many of them were
saying
the vaccine causes problems for the
vaccinated
person effects menstrual cycle
all this other stuff now many of them
have moved on to
i don't want to be near a vaccinated
person because just
it's emanating from their body they
never say are you breathing it out is it
coming out of your eyes is it coming out
of your ears is your skin releasing it
uh is it coming out of body odor they
never say but they're claiming
people are shedding vaccine and it's
making people around them feel sick and
i read about one employer
i forget what this some small business
said if you get vaccinated you will not
be allowed to come to work because
vaccinated people are shedding vaccine
and making others sick
i'm almost positive that that's against
the law to say you will be fired
if you are vaccinated uh but this is
getting really crazy and this is the
latest front in the anti-vax nonsense it
is
wild times but glad you were able to get
vaccinated very very good
we have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about wisconsin republicans
killing the medicaid expansion
we'll talk about the latest with my
pillow and we will talk about
an interesting hypothesis about what
jeff bezos is up to
with donald trump's apprentice tapes
okay
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get that bonus show my friends sign up
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman